hey you guys flickers of fear time
talking about a movie here that came out
several years ago and got a huge amount
of you know it was like really really uh
you know there's a lot of buzz around it
and um you know i remember hearing a lot
about it with a lot of people saying oh
this is you know the best horror movie
that came out in
decades and
it was like one of the best movies of
the you know 2010s or whatever what you
want to call it and i think i saw it
like a couple of years after it came out
after seeing like it uh hyped so much
and i remember liking it but not really
loving it and i'd be like yeah that was
good i get it but i was just kind of
like well maybe that was like the hype
was a little too much about it but then
i think i i just kept coming back to it
i think there was something about the
premise that i actually really liked
about it so i kept like re-watching it
and re-watching it and i think the more
times i've rewatched it i think i've
seen it four or five times at this point
i think like the more i pick up in it
because there's a really lot going on in
this movie um a lot of kind of visual
cues a lot of homages to older movies um
you know so there's kind of a lot of
visual stuff going on a lot of symbolism
that you might not necessarily catch
like the first time around as i said
it's a it's a simple premise but
in the sense of a lot of these kind of
like i said i hate to use this term but
like elevated horror movies the last few
years it could be read in several
different ways being like the monster if
you want to call it that in this movie
which we'll get into in a minute but
you could read it in a couple of
different ways like the monster could be
symbolic of a lot of different things or
you could just watch it as just like a
creepy simple you know straightforward
kind of throwback horror movie so this
is the movie it follows this came out
back in 2014
i think it got its first premiere
probably at sundance i feel like and
then it had like a limited release and
then went into much wider release it was
directed by david robert mitchell this
was his second film interesting it only
cost i think cost less than 2 million
i think it cost less than 1.5 million i
think it was 1.3 million and ended up
making after it went into wider release
like around the world ended up making
like about 23 million or more than that
so uh actually did very very well and
it's very easy to see why because
there's just something very this is not
i mean it's not like the scariest movie
i've ever seen but it you know in the
sense of you know jump scares or giving
me nightmares or anything like that but
the thing that this movie does really
well is that it just establishes this
really like unrelenting
sort of but low-key
feeling of dread like throughout the
whole thing like you know that you can't
really escape from this like there's
really no way of escaping this curse or
whatever it is you want to call it so
the whole movie is just kind of like
you're just kind of like
tense like because you're kind of
waiting you know something bad is going
to happen and it's kind of like but and
and like i said you're still trying to
you like the whole time i was watching
it like your brain is going like how
could you even how could you even like
stop this how could you avoid like how
could there ever be an end to it and
there really wouldn't be um i will say
too though that it's i one thing that i
really like about the movie is that
david robert mitchell has said
that
he got the idea for it follows he's like
not specifically but he's like when i
was growing up um you know when my
parents divorced and stuff like that i
started having all these nightmares
about being followed by a person and
they were like really really creepy and
you know just really there was just like
somebody coming after me like
unrelentingly and i had a lot of dreams
like that so he's like so i wanted
to make a movie that tried to capture
that feeling and then like later on he
brought in the you know sexually
transmitted disease angle if you want to
call it that
um he's like because that wasn't part of
the original dreams because he had him
when he was younger but he's like so i
just i just really wanted to
capture that feeling of just being
followed and not being able to like
escape from it like this anxiety this
constant like low-key anxiety all the
time and i think he did a really really
good job of of capturing that in the
movie because that's exactly what this
movie has
now as i said it's almost kind of like a
throwback which a lot of really good
horror movies lately have been
interestingly he chose to it seems like
it's set in the modern day because one
of the characters yara i think her name
is she has like an e-reader that looks
like a little makeup compact or like a
birth control pill type of uh compact
thing it looks like that so it's
obviously and people have cell phones so
it's like obviously set in the modern
day but interestingly i guess he shot it
in detroit
and so a lot of the houses or
neighborhoods are really really run down
a lot of the cars are old a lot of the
insides of the houses are you know have
like old furniture so everything like
looks really old and rickety and the um
the characters seem like their clothes
are not really modern like you could
wear that and like no one would think it
was that weird but they're also kind of
like
they could be construed as being kind of
like from the late 70s or early 80s but
not overtly so so it gives the movie
this kind of dream like
unstuck in time sort of thing which i
think really works to its advantage
because you can't really pinpoint
you know it's it's very location based
for sure because like i said it's based
around detroit so it's this kind of like
everything looks really run down and
decrepit but it's not really like
pinpointed in any particular time period
so it's almost kind of like i mean
because obviously
john carpenter was a big touchstone for
this cause some of the shots like the
way they're framed and everything like
that are pretty much um exactly the way
they were shot or framed in halloween
from 1978 uh so you can tell that he was
homaging specific movies uh
you know on purpose i think also he said
like with the cinematography which is
gorgeous in this by the way he uses like
a lot of wide shots a lot of really long
takes and it really is uh effective and
like keeping this kind of anxiety or
dread inducing kind of feeling going um
i think he said to you that one of his
inspirations for the cinematography the
way that it was shot was uh the movie
paris texas which you know you can see
that as well but like i said very very
john carpenter very late 70s
kind of just this creepy dread inducing
like slow burn uh sort of horror and
like i said if you're gonna make a low
budget horror movie
do something like this because this is a
really smart
it's a concept that doesn't need a lot
of bells and whistles uh there aren't a
lot of you know there's not much cgi
there's not like a bunch of jump scares
there's a couple but not really you know
it's not really egregious and it's just
kind of like this i mean the thing about
it is that the story is so great the
premise is so great just this you know
this constant sense of dread is great
and another thing too that i think is
cool about this is that all the
characters in it are just regular
likable people because i kind of feel
like
a lot of more
mainstream or generic sort of horror
movies and some independent ones too
they tend to make especially if it's
kind of like a slasher movie type of
thing which
this is kind of like a slasher movie i
guess you could like loosely say it was
a slasher movie even though it sort of
has some supernatural elements even
though they're not really explained but
i think that's kind of a good thing
but i kind of feel like in a lot of
slasher movies you're almost kind of
like
all the characters are sort of like
archetypes or they're all kind of dicks
uh because in various ways because
you know the audience comes there like
to essentially root for the villain you
want to see the kills you want to see so
you want to see like these [ __ ] get
[ __ ] up you know what i mean but in
this one
the characters are just so
normal and they're not you know they're
not overtly just these horrible jerky
but they're just nice regular ass people
and so you actually kind of feel bad for
them like when all this [ __ ] starts to
happen because it's like holy crap like
what would you do
you know you're just a normal ass person
trying to live your normal ass life and
like all of a sudden this curse or
whatever it is
you know is kind of placed upon you
through no action of your own really um
you know through no fault of your own
and now you're
being pursued you're gonna die you you
know when all your other friends are
involved and stuff like that and it's
just kind of like a hopeless situation
and i think the likability of the
characters the regular nature of the
characters them not being
overly archetypers like oh here's the
[ __ ] here's the dork here's this that
and the other i think just making them
just a group of regular ass people was
really the right decision because they
just seem like relatable and they seem
very likable the opening shot of this or
the opening sequence of this movie is so
so great because
it does a lot without much dialogue i
think that's another thing that i really
like about this movie yes there's
dialogue in it obviously and there is
kind of like you know a scene where the
the premise the simple premise is sort
of explained but a lot of this stuff is
conveyed visually which
sadly even though movies are a visual
medium you don't really seem to see that
much i kind of feel like everything has
to be like x big x exposition dump like
everybody like talking about things in
the movie rather than showing things
happening in the movie but this really
doesn't seem to have that uh problem
so the opening sequence
is this girl you don't really uh know
her uh her name's annie if you look at
the wikipedia page
and she's basically just coming out of
her house
after you're led to presume that she's
had a date and she's like stayed over at
this person's house because she's kind
of in like a sexy nightie or whatever
and she's got high-heeled shoes on but
she comes like running out of this house
like in the dawn you know what it was in
the morning and she's obviously like
freaking out like scared kind of looking
behind her and [ __ ] like that and she's
kind of like running down the street and
people are asking you know hey you need
help or anything like that she's like no
no it's fine
and
so much is conveyed like through this
sequence that you know it doesn't need
to be explained because it's all visual
you're just kind of like sucked in
immediately because you're like what the
hell is going on with this girl uh so
you know so she's running down the
street and then finally she's like
looking around she doesn't see anything
so she goes back in the house and then
they show her later on and she's sitting
out on the beach by herself and she's
calling her parents
and she seems very upset and she's
telling them how much she loves them
and everything like that and then like
the next scene they cut to it and she's
obviously dead like her leg is broken
and like all backwards and all this
other kind of stuff so this opening
sequence like says so much obviously she
knew someone was after her we don't see
who it is we don't know what's going on
it's like the first time i saw it i
think well i mean i already knew the
premise but if you didn't know the
premise you know at first you'd be like
oh well she's paranoid about something
and then the phone call that she gives
it's like oh you think oh maybe she's
gonna kill herself or anything like that
but then when they show the body uh
you're like yeah well obviously she
didn't do that to herself so someone was
after her and someone got her in the end
and so like i said that just couple
minute sequence really really sets
everything up like really effectively
so after that happens then we switch to
our main protagonist this girl named jay
uh her actual name is jamie i think but
they just call her jay for short
and she's been dating this new guy named
hugh they seem to be you know it's kind
of a new thing but they seem to like
like each other or whatever
and uh you know somebody asked her like
one of her friends she has like a she
has a sister and like the sisters couple
friends they all kind of like hang out
at the house together or whatever the
sister is kind of asking oh you you know
if you and hugh had sex yet and she's
like no not yet you know think about it
whatever so she they so they go out on
the date you know uh hugh and jay
and they go to this movie
and uh interestingly they start playing
this game where she basically says me
and my sister used to play this um you
know we imagined
we would pick a person in a crowd and
like imagine what like would we want to
trade places with that person and like
why would we want to trade places that
person then the other person has to
guess like which person you picked and
why you want to trade places with them
so they kind of play this game and then
they were sitting in they're sitting in
the movie theater
and she's going and she's like okay i
picked a person and then hugh's trying
to guess who it is and he's like oh i
bet you picked that girl in the yellow
dress and she turns around and she's
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
there's nobody there's no girl in a
yellow dress back there and he's like no
she's right there she's right there and
she doesn't see anything at which point
he starts getting like really weirded
out he's like yeah we we gotta go like i
really don't feel very well
so she's just kind of like okay whatever
like
he's acting really strange and
everything like that and again you don't
really know like what the [ __ ] the deal
is is he seeing things is was there
somebody there and then they're gone you
don't really know
so then later on
they go out to this sort of abandoned
like factory or whatever
and uh they're gonna have sex in the car
and uh right after they have sex in the
car she's kind of like you know just
hanging out like talking to him or
whatever he jumps on her and chloroforms
her uh at which point you're kind of
like okay now what the [ __ ] is going on
so she wakes up and he has strapped her
to a wheelchair like inside the factory
and he's basically says i'm sorry i had
to do this but um i had to do this to
prove to you that this is real it's a
curse
it follows you this person can whoever
this person is that's following you it
can take any form that it wants to it
can be a stranger in a crowd it can be
someone you know
um so it could look like your friend it
could look like your mom it could look
like anybody but they're like basically
it will just keep walking toward you
until you pass it to somebody else the
thing about it though is that so he has
passed it to her because they had sex
it's sexually transmitted
and
the thing about it though is that if it
kills the person that you passed it to
then it will come back and start going
after you again so it's awes so
basically the only way to get rid of it
is just like to pass it on to somebody
else have them not get killed and have
them pass it on to somebody else until
essentially you have
so many degrees of separation that it's
not gonna come after you but it's like
like i said that's kind of like shitty
because even if you
were kind of like okay well i just gotta
go bang somebody else real quick and
like [ __ ] pass it to that person but
if you don't tell that person what's
going on
um then that person will inevitably get
killed because they won't know what the
[ __ ] like somebody's just gonna walk up
on them and kill them and then it's just
gonna come back to you anyway so it's
not like an easy thing where you can
just pass it to somebody and be like
phew you know that's over so it's like
this really complex type of thing and
like i said i kind of like
i like that simple premise it's very
easy to understand it's not and i like
that he um you know the director david
robert mitchell he was basically like i
didn't he's like i just wanted to make
it like dream logic it's like it doesn't
have to make sense is it is it a demon
is it supernatural doesn't matter um
it's just kind of like like a nightmare
that's what he wanted to make it's like
a nightmare but kind of said in reality
and so i really like that the [ __ ]
wasn't like over explained i like that
there wasn't this thing like let's let's
go back to the history and see where
this first this demon first came from or
anything like that that does it that's
[ __ ] and it does it's not important
you know it's just scary because it's
like basically you have sex with
somebody that has this curse and now you
have it and basically you are going to
get followed by various people and you
won't know who they are they'll just
start walking right at you and uh you
can't get rid of it
like i said even if you pass it to
somebody else if something bad if that
person gets killed by the by the it then
it will come back and get you you know
so you really like i said you can't
really escape it so obviously if if hugh
had just told her this uh she wouldn't
have believed it so that's why
uh he was smart enough to
uh essentially strap her to a chair and
be like okay i'm gonna prove it to you
so while they're at the factory she's
strapped to this wheelchair and a naked
woman basically like starts walking
right at her and he's like see do you
see it um and he can still see it too
even though he has passed on to somebody
else because that's i guess once the
curse has gone through you you can see
the person but see that's the thing
nobody else can see it unless you have
the curse right now or if you
had it and then passed it somebody else
so then like you can see the it that's
coming at you but nobody else can see it
so other people think you're like a
lunatic because you just like see this
person like coming at you and they're
gonna kill you and you're just like it's
right there and nobody can see anything
so there's so there's that thing too
like she kind of thinks she's going nuts
so she has seen this naked woman so she
believes it
and uh so basically she has to go back
to her house now this thing is like
pursuing her in various forms like she's
at school and like this creepy old woman
like starts walking across the you know
the campus like toward her window and
she's like flipping out and everything
so she basically has to tell she tells
her friends and they don't believe her
but she sees like the it like coming at
her in different forms in her house and
they don't see it but the interesting
thing though is that even though they
don't see it i guess like the it can do
like
if it does physical things like it
breaks a window or at one point like it
pulls her up by the hair like nobody
around her can see the it
they can't see the person but they can
see the effect that the person is having
on her like they can see the hair being
pulled up they just can't see like who
it is that's doing it so at this point
she tries to go back and get more
answers from hugh at which point uh she
finds out that hugh is not the dude's
real name he was actually at the school
like or he had changed his name he was
rented a house under like false
pretenses so she does a little bit of
sleuthing and they find out and they
find out uh what the dude's actual name
is like his name is jeff and he'd gone
to this other school and so they go back
to him and try to get more answers but
he just like flips out he's like hey
look i just got it from this one night
stand girl i don't know anything else to
tell you we shouldn't even be in the
same area uh you know get the [ __ ] away
from me so there's that kind of whole
thing too so basically most of the movie
is jay trying to avoid getting killed by
this thing and also she has a couple of
friends
uh like one guy that lives next door and
then there's this one dude named paul
who i guess they i guess he was like a
neighbor
and uh he had grown up they had grown up
together like you know he had he had
hung out at their house all the time
when they were all kids and paul has
always kind of like carried a torch for
her so there's this whole thing too
where
some of the guys like one of the guys
that um is like the the sort of bad boy
like the sort of neighbor he kind of
gets involved in the [ __ ] too
uh because you know they're she's acting
weird one day out in the yard and like
he's she tries to see what's going on
and when she actually they you know they
try to run away they go out to like this
remote lake house and it's you know
there's all this kind of [ __ ] where the
where it still finds her and she takes
off in a car and crashes it and has to
go to the hospital now while she's in
the hospital uh the bad boy who i think
his name is greg
but i think he doesn't
he doesn't actually believe her
completely because like i said he can't
see the it he can't see the person and
even though he sees like what appears to
be sort of like poltergeist activity
like i said because you can still see
you know [ __ ] happening around that you
just can't see the person but he doesn't
really seem to believe it so he has sex
with her in the hospital like
consensually she doesn't you know she's
it's not like she's not unconscious or
anything like that because um you know
he's like i guess well oh i'll take it
on i can handle it or whatever but i
don't think he entirely believes it's
going to happen and it's weird because
it almost seems like
the curse isn't gonna affect him because
he comes back and he says yeah it's been
three days and i haven't
seen anything
but it turns out the curse uh gets him
in the end anyway he gets killed so then
uh the curse ends up regressing back to
jay at which point you know she has to
like again figure out how they're gonna
uh they're gonna get rid of it and what
they decide to do i guess this seems
very strange there's i kind of like that
there's no scene
where
i like that there's no scene of like
investigating like the history of the it
like of the demon or whatever they're
just kind of like okay well this is the
situation how are we going to get out of
it that's because there's nothing you
could really do like i said other than
like humping somebody else or just like
running away from it every time you see
it you know and hope that it doesn't
catch up with you you know what i mean
so it's that kind of thing there's not
really a lot you can do to stop it but
there's no scene where they come up with
this plan because the plan that they
come up with is they're like well
let's um once it goes back to jay it's
like let's put her like they go to this
um like a sports center or the school or
whatever and they go into like this
place where the big swimming pool is and
they're like let's put her in the middle
of the swimming pool like as bait and
then when the it comes like to get her
like we'll see it when it goes into the
water and then she'll jump out real
quick and then we'll throw a bunch of
electrical [ __ ] like a bunch of
appliances and [ __ ] in the water and
electrocute it because apparently
there it's not real clear like i said
because it's like supernatural pretty
much because at one point she shoots one
of the it's that's coming after her
that's actually taken the form of yara
and it does fall down but then it gets
back up again so they're kind of
presuming well maybe we can destroy it
because you know what else are you gonna
do right so it's you gotta try something
so they kind of do that but it doesn't
really work out as well it's kind of
well it seems like they destroy it i
like too that there's one point where
they're trying to because like i said
she's the only one that can see it so
she's in the pool going it's like right
there it's right there and like they
just so the dude's like shooting at it
and he's like he can't see it and at one
point i think they like toss a sheet
over it so it's there it's just like
invisible to everybody that doesn't have
the curse so when they put the sheet
over it it you know there is like a
figure that they can shoot at and and
all this other kind of stuff so it does
seem
that like they they have it in the in
the pool and they like they shoot at it
and it's like they and it seems like it
works because like the pool like fills
with blood and everything like that so
they don't really know but it's not
really clear if uh the it was destroyed
because like i said i don't really know
if it can be destroyed as i said this is
sort of like you know the movie it's not
it's like has nightmare logic so after
that happens her and paul you know the
childhood friend that has had a crush on
her all this time now they have sex so
if this is still around uh it'll be
after him now but like i said if but he
knows about it so now if if he gets
killed then we'll come back to her or
whatever but now it turns out that
uh the last shot of the movie which i
really really like
is jay and paul just like walking down
the street hand in hand and there's like
in the distance like behind them there's
like a figure following them now it
could just be a random ass person or it
could be the it we're not entirely sure
uh what it is but see the interesting
thing about this like i said i kind of
feel like because uh the curse the demon
whatever you want to call it
is
sexually transmitted a lot of people
like compared it to oh it's like a
sexually transmitted disease
uh which i guess you could call it that
but honestly
watching it i was kind of like i don't
even think that's it's that specific i
think the it just represents
death or aging or something like that
it's just something that's always there
it's always creeping up on you and it's
gonna get you like in the end whether
you like it or not so which is kind of
like a you know the pretty scary premise
if you think about it so i don't even
think it's as specific as and i don't
even think it's as specific as because i
know a lot of slasher movies are kind of
like you know punish teenagers for
having sex type of thing like or being
promiscuous so that's another thing i
like about this movie too is that they
didn't they didn't really make an issue
like he didn't make an issue of the
characters being [ __ ] or anything like
that they were just having
sex like a normal person would have you
know what i mean it wasn't like a big
huge deal
uh you know and it's like no one was
slut-shamed or anything like that it was
just like a regular part of life you
there was this risk of this fit of
catching this thing and like not being
able to get rid of it but like i said i
don't even know
i i don't know like from my point of
view i think the it was like symbolic
like i said of
of aging or
death you know what i mean it's because
it's always like creeping up on you it's
slow like it doesn't run and they even
say that at the beginning it's like it
just walks but it'll find you like in
the end if you drive far away eventually
like it will get to you and like i said
it'll take a different form uh during
the course of the movie it turns up as
like friends of hers it turns up as her
dead dad it turns up as you know her uh
her neighbor's mom it turns up as like
different people and it turns up as
strangers as well so that's the thing
you never know so like i said that's why
to me it seems like it represents death
because it's kind of like one it's
always out there it's always coming at
you and it's always gonna get you in the
end but also you don't know
when it's gonna get you you can't you
don't know what to expect you know what
i mean you don't know what form it's
gonna take so to me that was kind of
like so it was kind of like a bigger
statement about that i really really
like and i mean i think i've brought
this up before but i really really like
these low-key kind of just creepy dread
inducing
kind of anxiety-ridden
sort of movies you like i said you don't
need jump scares you don't need cgi you
don't like special effects there's just
something really really creepy
about
being somewhere and like just not
feeling safe because you never know when
this person's just gonna like just a
random ass person is just gonna start
like walking at you and you know and
like i said there's really no way to get
rid of it there's no way out of it even
if you pass it on to somebody else it's
like you know you never know if that
person's gonna get killed in a few days
and then it's gonna come back after you
again so it's just you're kind of like
[ __ ] either way so i really really
like that sort of unrelenting and it's
just kind of it's low-key but it's like
really really unrelenting and i really
really like that like i said i love uh
the shot compositions of this are great
the [ __ ] framing and everything very
very retro very throwback but has its
own style as well uh so i just really
really like that um also got to give a
shout out to the [ __ ] score by
disasterpiece which is
amazing uh very very reminiscent of late
70s early 80s horror movies which
reminded me of like john carpenter or
like giallo movies or something like
that just that kind of like cynthia kind
of scored it looks like i really really
like that and i really like too i think
if i'm remembering it correctly that i
think there's only like a lot of music
or like this kind of relentless like
cynthia music when the it is somewhere
like in the vicinity so
it's just it's so great because it's one
of those movies that because you never
know what form it is gonna take you're
always like watching the perimeter of
the frame it's like who's that person
back there who's that person and they
even like uh they even use that like
some of the characters would be like you
know there'd be like a person walking
towards like who's that do you see that
person you know what i mean and it's
like yeah we see that person so that's
like a real person but that's but that's
what's so cool about it is that you
don't know what form it's gonna take you
don't know what it looks like so it
could be anybody it could just be like
lurking around in the background and
then suddenly it comes walking at you
and it's just like there's something
just so simple and primal but also
something really creepy about that and i
think it was really really effectively
done so i can see why
this got such a massive uh you know just
massive buzz when this came out and it's
still cited as one of the best horror
movies of the 2010s which i would agree
with as well um it's like i said if you
don't like slow burn horror movies you
don't like retro movies if you like
something that's more like action-packed
and [ __ ] like that then yeah you
probably are not going to dig it too
much because it is very low-fi it is
very uh low-key but
to me that kind of just makes it
creepier it's just and it's even though
and i like that it has this sort of like
grounded in reality but also like this
sort of vaguely nightmarish feel to it
as well and like i said i think it helps
too that the mythology of the it is not
really explained and i don't think it
needs to be and i think the movie is a
lot better for not explaining it because
like i said it's a very simple easy to
understand premise you don't need to
complicate it you don't need to like
[ __ ]
you know like i said you don't need to
like investigate it or anything like
that it's just like a problem this thing
is coming after you what are you going
to do
you know where are you going to go how
are you going to fix it and that's
basically all they do they don't need to
like
mythologize or over explain or anything
like that and i think that's really
really great it's just kind of just a
very very simple premise and it's just
very very effective so this movie if you
have not seen it probably just spoiled
all of it but that's okay that's what i
usually do that's what i do uh this is
actually available uh i thought it was
available on hulu but i think you have
to have like one of the expensive
add-ons if you want to watch it however
i believe you can watch it on pluto tv
for free uh i actually rented it on
amazon prime for 3.99 so there's various
places you can see it and i really
really do recommend it if you like
this sort of slow burn retro uh type of
horror uh from like the 2010s which
there was a lot of them kind of like
that and i think this is easily one of
the best ones so if you haven't seen it
uh definitely check out it follows from
2014 and i will see you guys on the next
flickers of fear
bye